[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello you took just Lois my friends this
is guns in here welcome to my new
episode where I'm going to show you a
complete replica and a tricky line
against Evans gambit now the opening
arises after the following order
efore 'if i Knight to f3 Knight to c6
Bishop to c4 Bishop to c5 and now the
characteristic Evans gambit moved before
this whole romantic gambit is still
popular nowadays the simple reason is it
has a tremendous attacking potential
however in modern era where pro engines
grabs every single material if it's
possible I think we are all set to
surprise our opponent the line I have
recommended in this video has not only a
surprise value but in many lines black
obtain a decent position with a solid
pawn advantage here my recommendation is
you certainly take this pawn and after
the move c3 as I have highlighted over
here these are the most popular choices
by the black but we are going to play a
super surprising move Bishop to d6
hahaha well with this move what black is
announcing is look you have sacrificed
your pawn and now show me where is your
compensation now that is one important
point I like to mention before we move
on that is due to the time constraint I
cannot go each and every line in detail
so I am going to pause at certain point
where black obtain a decent advantage
however you can look out this lines in
the PGN which is available in the
description in this position what has
the only good reply that is d4 the other
choice Queen to b3 is not good at all
the simple reason is after the move
Queen to e7 d4 and now
Knight to e5 and black get the bishop
pair with solid pawn advantage so
accordingly the menu over here is d4 and
after that as per theory the men who is
Knight to f6 but I am NOT going to
propose in this lecture instead of that
my recommendation is you continue with
the MU at six and completely taken out
wide from it's all preparation now there
is an important point over here that
white can never play the Moody file
which is a positional blunder because
after the move defy black can continue
with the move Knight to e5 attacking the
bishop Bishop to d3 and after Knight to
f6 castle Castle Knight B to d2 and the
move b6 I think this is more or less
plan of campaign by black so what black
actually want to do is he wants to play
rook to e8 Bishop to b7 Bishop to f/8
and then consolidate his Center with the
move d6 and asking white hey I'm upon up
and where is your attack so remember
this setup guys and most of the scenario
we are trying to obtain this setup okay
let's follow the main line theory here
White Castle on the Kings side now black
can play the move Knight to f6 attacking
efore and the main line will continue
with the rope - even now instead of rook
to e1 in one blitz game my opponent
immediately tried to open up the center
with the move D captures ePHI but I
don't think so black has any trouble
because after the accurate reply Bishop
captures ePHI Knight captures ePHI
Knight captures ePHI black is attacking
the bishop so white has to forcefully
move the bishop and now black and
continue with the Moody six why it's
idea is to grab the center with the MU
f4 but the following sequence night to
see
6e phi d captures ePHI Queen captures
Knight captures pawn captures and now
Knight to d7 and not only black is a
clear point up but white has some
shattered pawn which is always a big
time problem when your attack doesn't
work okay rook to even and now black
should castle on the Kings side now when
I check this position with the online
database there is one good point I found
out about this position from the black
perspective is there are only few games
played as for the database and you can
see the result they are pretty amazing
for the black so this is a great weapon
if you are looking for a win against
Evans gambit the mainline move over here
is Knight B to d2 but we should see the
second alternative which is occasionally
played by the white what you should do
when your opponent plays Knight to h4
well against this my recommendation is
you should certainly take this d4 pawn
and now why it's idea is to plonk the
knight on the lovely FY square and
meantime attacking the bishop but black
should not worry because after Bishop to
c5 c kept his d4 and Bishop to b6 yes
why it has a good center but with one D
pawn move black has consolidated his
extra pawn white can try over here move
such as ePHI or defy but it doesn't
leads to anything for example if you
play ePHI then the simplicity is you
counter check with the mu d phi and
after pawn captures and Bishop to a5
pawn captures g7 and now look to e8 with
a winning position for the black-white
cannot move this bishop for example if
we move somewhere let's say Bishop to b3
then after Bishop captures d4 white
indeed is going to lose the piece
instead of v5 what happens if your
opponent plays it
well more or less same story here black
and continue with the Moon Knight to e5
attacking the bishop and after the move
Bishop to b3 but Ike has a strong move
Knight F to g4 and it's funny that in
the game White has sacrifice a pawn to
get attacked by black so that's why the
mainline move over here is Knight B to
d2 after that black should continue with
the move rook to e8 now as I have
highlighted over here White has plenty
of choices but against each of them our
plan of campaign will remain same so we
want to play Bishop to f8 b6 Bishop e7
and then look out for the right moment
to play d6 or defy there are very few
games played from this position so
though all the analysis I have done it's
by myself and almost all the lines black
get at least slight initiative or the
advantage the first more I want to
consider is Knight to have fun which is
not a good move the simple reason is
after he captures d4c captors d4 and
rook captures evil black emerge with a
two-point advantage the second move I
want to consider is Queen to c2
well if white is not interrupting of a
plan then we don't have any problems
here obviously we are going to continue
with the movie six and now two moves has
been tried from this position against
Knight to have fun my recommendation is
you continue with the move Bishop to be
7 and after Knight to g3 he captures d4
why it's idea is to play Knight to f5
and if allowed then [ __ ] the black
pawn well obviously we are not going to
allow this so the correct moves and
Bishop to a fade and after C captures d4
d5
Black has achieved his all Trump's with
a solid point
advantage
I reached this position in a friendly
match against a very good opponent where
he continued with the move he captures
d5
I responded with the night to be for
attacking the Queen and if allowed then
blackened we kept to the pole with a
very good position my opponent try the
move rook to e8 but after the following
sequence that is Knight captures Queen
rook captures Queen rook captures rook
rook to be even and Bishop captures defy
after the whole sequence black has free
of all his pieces with a still pond of
advantage the second move Bishop to b2
has more or less same idea here we are
going to continue with the move Bishop
to b7 and after the Moon Knight to have
fun we can take this d4 pawn so at first
glance it looks like what has this
impressive center but here black has
this amazing shot rook captures efore
and black is coming on top from all the
variations Black's idea is after rook
captures efore he wants to play Knight
to be for attacking two spots so wide
response is force why it has to play
Queen to b3 but after following sequence
that is Bishop captures Bishop captures
f7 check King to h8 if Knight to e5 then
Queen to f8 is a very good reply so one
of the game continued here with the move
Knight 1 to D 2 but then comes fish up
to d5 Bishop captures Knight captures
and black has simplified some of the PCs
with a still pond advantage position the
third move I want to consider is Bishop
to d3
well after that black has 2 choices the
more sharper choices he captures d4
which I have covered in the PGN however
my recommendation is more safer Bishop
to f8 so now if allowed then black is
lately looking for the move d6 or d5 so
wide response is force White has to take
this pawn and no matter however he takes
the pawn let's say T captures e5
then black can continue with the Moon
Knight captures ePHI Knight captures
ePHI and now route to ePHI the most
critical response over here is f4 but if
your opponent plays moves such as Knight
to f3 then the simplest is you play rook
to e8 and after the move 'if i black
should continue with the move Knight to
d5 attacking c3 Queen to c2 and now d6
free of both the bishop with material
advantage and look at white he has some
horrible pawns where no attack to speak
off I have attached a sample game in the
PG and so kindly go through it so let's
look at the most critical reply f4 we're
here
rook to e8 is forced and now ePHI again
Knight to d5 hitting f4 heating c3 but
White has a sneaky reply that is Queen
to f3 here black cannot take this pawn
because after Bishop to see to attacking
denied like his forced to play ugly move
Bishop to b4 as if you try to escape
this Knight via the route Knight to be
Phi then after Queen to d3 black is
going to lose a piece so that's why
greedy move Knight to c3 is not possible
so instead of that my recommendation is
you should continue with the moves c6 I
raise this position three times in
online games and these are the three
applies try by my opponent so let's see
each my turn in the first game my
opponent try the move F Phi which looks
so aggressive but I think after Bishop
check King to h1 and the move d6 black
has diffused all the threats if Bishop
to b2 then D captures Aoife is a very
strong
reply so in the game my opponent try the
move Knight to c4 keeping all the
tension but I'm afraid this move is not
good enough because after D captures
ePHI rook captures ePHI and the move b
phi black get a decisive advantage again
continue with the move rook check queen
takes and now Knight to d2 which allows
Queen to sweep down to the other side of
the board with the Queen check push up
to have fun and now lovely move Bishop
to have to so black has a very simple
threat of night to e3 my opponent try
the move Queen to e2 but after Bishop
captures fi it is very clear that black
obtained two-point advantage with a very
aggressive settle in the second game my
opponent try the move c4 but I think
this is less accurate because after
night to be for attacking the bishop
bishop to be even and now d6 free up
blacks position he tried a three but
this is all prepared as I continue with
the move he captures ePHI and white
cannot even touch this night or this
pawn for example if we take this night
then after Queen to d4 White is going to
lose an exchange probably the most
critical reply over here is Knight to c4
but against this our plan of campaign
was very consistent yep we are going to
play the d6 open our bishops and
undermining the white center if fi then
b phi is a very strong reply so in the
game my opponent try the move Bishop to
d2 but after D captures ePHI Knight
captures ePHI Knight to f6 Bishop to e3
and the move Bishop to e6 where it has a
very simple plan of campaign where White
has no attack to speak off
the forth more I want to consider is
Bishop to b3 well against this my
recommendation is you continue with the
move Knight to e5
so if allowed then black is definitely
going to take this bishop pair so for
example let's say Bishop to b2 the
knight captures pawn captures pawn
captures pawn captures and now Bishop to
b4 with a wonderful position so
obviously your opponent is not going to
allow this and he is going to play this
theoretical move Knight to c4 so white
idea is to not only pressurizing the e5
square but in some lies might can get of
a dark square Bishop and ruin our pawn
structure well here black response is
force black has to take this night and
after Bishop captures my recommendation
is you play this pawn sacrifice line
where you're giving back the material
but in return you get a very good active
position it doesn't matter whether Y
take this Foreman or play Bishop to d3
let's see the most critical line that is
Bishop captures beef I fish up to b7
pressurizing the e4 and a simple line
can run like this defy rook to b8 rook
to be 1 Bishop to c5 Bishop to d2 Knight
to g4 attacking f2 root 2 e 2 and now
the center undermining moves c6 the line
continue with the Moody cap to c6 Bishop
captures c6 Bishop captures rook
captures Queen captures pawn captures
after the whole sequence yes indeed
White has restored the material balance
but if you carefully look at this
position black has more active minor
pieces than white and that's why this
position is advantageous to the black
ok let's consider the most critical
reply by white that is Queen to b3 so
white is pressurizing the f7 square
which black has
to defend with the move Queen to e7 with
this move Black has created a thread so
white has to deal with this and
accordingly the mainline move is Bishop
to d3
now instead of Bishop to d3 in one game
my opponent try the Moon Knight to h4
which has the idea of distracting the
black play but black should not be
afraid of this as after Knight to a5
attacking two spots Queen to e5 if you
take this bishop then after Knight to c4
black position doesn't look good so my
recommendation is you continue with the
move b6 allowing this Knight to f5 idea
afterwards
black will play Queen to f8 now if I
take this Bishop then we can take back
with our queen and the resulting
position is completely fine for the
black so my opponent try the move push
up to d3 I continue with my piece
development that is Bishop to b7 and now
he connected his rook with the move
Bishop to b2
well so far white is doing good but
after blacks necks forcing reply that is
Bishop to c6 attacking the Queen Queen
to c2 and now Bishop to e3 by exchanging
the dark square bishop not only black
will reduced the attacking power of the
white but later on black can play the
move g6 kick this Knight out of his
territory and remain a solid point
advantage with a wonderful position so
as per the theory main line move over
here is Bishop to d3
well after that my recommendation is you
continue with the move Knight to h4
attacking the Queen Queen to a4 and now
b6 and continue with our thematic plan
okay white will continue with his normal
idea that is knight to have fun Bishop
to b7 and now Knight to g3 looks good
right but one problem it's slow and we
can exploit this with the move he
captures d4 Knight to f5 Quint where
fate
and now it has this too critical reply
first move Aoife is not a good move the
simple reason is after Bishop captures
f3 black obtained a very good advantage
kindly note if G captures f3 then Bishop
captures ePHI and black has a winning
position so the critical line runs with
the mu C captures D for supporting the
center black should certainly save this
bishop with the move Bishop to c6 Queen
to d1 and now Knight to d5
okay white get his piece back but after
rook check Queen captures and now rook
to e8 attacking the Queen Queen to d1
pawn captures d6 and this time around
black has to pawn advantage okay what
happens if you open and take this bishop
well of course here time being it will
double of a pawn but now black is
attacking three times on the a four
square and funny enough that pawn cannot
go forward so white has to defend this
pawn and the way to do is Queen captures
v-fold but after the following sequence
that is rook to ecigs fish up to a3
Queen - eight nine to d2 instead of
night to d2 if white foolishly take this
pawn
then after Knight to c6 what is going to
lose a piece so that's not a possible so
Knight 2 d2 is one of the best reply
after that black can unravel his pawn
structure with the moon defy and after
Aoife and Knight to c6
once again black obtain a two-point
advantage
well I hope you enjoy and learn my
tricky pet line against Evans gambit so
far I have amazing winning ratio with
this setup
and today I have shared my secret with
you hope you had wonderful success in
your game as well feel free to like
subscribe and comment on my video and
I'll meet you in my next episode very
soon bye and take care